All right. So I was tasked today to present our data, our institutional data on lancastuximab
with rituximab in patients with relapsed refractory follicular lymphoma.
So as a background, frontline therapy for follicular lymphoma is well-defined.
The standard approach in the relapse setting is less so, although that's probably changing
with the recent approval of epicaritamab.
Lancastuximab-tucerin is an antibody drug conjugate comprising a humanized anti-CD19
antibody, which is conjugated to tucerin, an alkylating agent.
In the initial phase one study of lancastuximab, the drug demonstrated an overall response
rate of 78% and a complete response of 64%.
So we conducted a phase two study investigating this.
So this is the study schema.
We included patients with follicular lymphoma meeting the GELF criteria for treatment in
addition to POD24 and patients having their second and beyond relapse.
The treatment schema includes lancastuximab given every three weeks in an induction period
combined with rituximab.
And after 12 weeks, we included lancastuximab.
So we included lancastuximab given every three weeks in an induction period combined with rituximab.
And after 12 weeks, we included lancastuximab given every three weeks in an induction period combined with rituximab.
PET-CTs are done, and that defines the primary outcome of CR at 12 weeks.
Subsequently, patients achieving a response get a maintenance phase,
followed by extended maintenance phase if they continue to have a response.
For patients with CR, they got rituximab alone.
For patients with partial response, they completed on lancastuximab.
The total treatment is less than 10 months.
So the median follow-up for this study is that,
this study that I'm presenting today is 18 months.
And as I mentioned, the primary outcome is CR at 30 months.
So baseline characteristics, looking at this patient population,
there were about 30% of those patients having prior transformed disease and grade 3A as well.
Looking at the Flippy score, more than 60% had high Flippy score,
and POT24 represented half of those.
So that's a lot more than the average population.
High tumor burden by the GALF criteria was more than 90%.
So that was the main inclusion criteria that was met.
Looking at the side effect profile,
cytopenia, specifically neutropenia and lymphopenia were grade 3 and above,
were present in more than 10% of patients.
Additionally, some unique side effects for lancastuximab,
the RAP.
The rash and the photosensitivity were grade 1 and 2 mostly,
and were present in 35% and 15% of the population, respectively.
A third spacing can occur in lancastuximab.
So pleural effusion grade 1 and 2 were reported in about 12% of patients.
This is the primary outcome.
So at week 12, the overall response rate was 97.4.
And the CR rate was 66.7% for the overall population.
When looking at best response, this improved with the CR rate reaching 76.9%.
Looking at high-risk groups within follicular lymphoma,
we see that lancastuximab achieves very high overall response rates and CR rates
across the different risk groups.
So looking at POT24, high-risk Flippy score and prior transformed follicular lymphoma
and double refractory patients, they all had very similar outcomes with overall response
rates approaching 90 and 100%.
Looking at the survival curves at 12 months, the progression-free survival was 94.6%.
The overall survival was also 94.1%.
And that was at 12 months.
So building on this, we are expanding this IIT to be in multiple centers across the United
States.
And we are also adjusting the schedule so patients will finish the whole treatment in
less than five months, basically, if they achieve a CR or PR at week 12.
Those patients are receiving two additional doses of lancastuximab and rituximab and complete
study at that point.
We're also going to be measuring ctDNA throughout different time points as well.
So as a conclusion, limited duration lancastuximab and rituximab drive significant CR rate in
the second line and later follicular lymphoma.
This study met its primary endpoint with a week 12.
And the CR appeared to be prolonged, our 12-month PFS of 94.6% validates that and not reaching
the median PFS.
The safety profile within follicular lymphoma is consistent with prior studies in large
B-cell lymphoma.
Most adverse events were grade 1 and 2, so they were low grade, including hyperglycemia
and elevated liver enzymes.
In the second line, we saw a decrease in the amount of lancastuximab and rituximab, and
a decrease in the amount of C-cell lymphoma.
So this study suggests that fixed-duration program of lancastuximab with rituximab is
a promising combination in the second line and beyond.
So I'd like to thank everyone within our group in the lymphoma and acknowledge the PI of this
study, Dr. Alderuccio, and our lymphoma section chief, Dr. Isidore Losos.
Thank you.